signori si corre questo gioco tratta di
pelati io l'ho gioco perché i pelati io
provo compassione perché mio padre lo è
siamo su tir simulator quindi ladro
simulator lo vedi che sicuramente non fa
il fioraio e questa cosa mi sembra
abbastanza chiara un profilo su sorella
gioca bene vi spiego all'acquisto un
gioco che tratta di persone che rubano i
soldi youtubers quindi bisogna rubare
nella casa delle persone adesso noi
dobbiamo capire visto che non ho fatti
di giochi dove devi rubare le cose devo
capire come come emesso questo sembra
molto bello visto che costa 20 euro che
non è l'unica la data è stata comprare
questo gioco cioè mi hanno potuto i
soldi a me prova beh le cose a caso va
bene gruppo lupo nelle cose c'è questo
scava il john moore e tra un piede di
porco per terra pronto vini rendiconti
diversi si prendono preso a poi puoi
comprare gli strumenti per per rubare le
cose o 15 dollari che schifo ruba punto
io affitta ladro punto it black veil
vabbè a perché quanto puoi vendere le
cose o genti richiesti ma che alla
pentola perché la gente chiede una
pentola su blackberry non puoi andare su
amazon a chiedere pentole no su black
andiamo su il sito dei ladri voglio una
pentola rubata solo pentole rubate sta
gente va bene e andiamo a forzare la
porta stato non sono per niente
riconoscibile che sono un ladro
interagisci grimaldello semplice non ce
l'ho non tengo il grimaldello aver
rubiamo senza il grimaldello andiamo a
così ma scavalcano in un posto
scavalcato la recinzione danneggiata vai
chi se ne frega della serratura vai così
perché uno dovrebbe lasciare dei soldi
dietro la l'immondizia perché tostapane
che lo vendo al banco dei pegni la
pentola che si vende su ebay e un sacco
di esordi tegami tegami apro l'ikea dopo
rubata qua ho rubato un sacco di roba
chi se ne frega nessuno ha visto via
salve buona giornata a lei molto meglio
l'altro questa è la mia uffici cioè io
vivo qua praticamente deposita il
deposito
positano roma che figata è fatto
benissimo chi è che ha sviluppato gioco
lupin compiute in italia se riesco a
vendere su ebay sta roba sul blackberry
scusatemi cucina pentole vendi perfetta
la teiera non ce l'abbiamo purtroppo
adesso 100 dollari
fantastico attrezzi per ladri allora sta
roba costa 52mila dollari
cosa devo hackerare mark zuckerberg
dispositivo per la nave telecomando
dell'auto o dormiamo e domani rubiamo un
sacco di allora è l'una e luna ha ceduto
il pomeriggio per rubare fatto solo part
time oggi tutto il pomeriggio per rubare
rubiamo andiamo in una casa molto più
ricca chissenefrega di quelli che ci
danno le informazioni non me ne frega
niente di fano se noi noi sappiamo come
entrare in casa perché noi possiamo
veniamo riuscito entra lista casa qua
c'è il credo che sia impossibile per lo
meno rubare in una casa così grande se
non ai suggerimenti europa perché stavo
sarebbe troppo semplice però io potrei
stupirvi tutti quanti
sì però non posso rubare in una casa
così di giorno la gado andare di notte
torniamoci di notte allora ragazzi e
l'una di notte ce la possiamo fare
ripeto credo fortemente che una casa del
genere richiede a livelli superiori
perché secondo me è impossibile però
vabbè proviamoci giacché non puoi
entrare perché non puoi sfondare nulla
posso provare a bussare magari questi
qua ecco forse questi qua sono un po più
easy perché qualora vi serve il
grimaldello semplice che ancora non ho
sbloccato e ci metto poco herat a
sbloccarlo quadri mandela automatico
porco demonio ma dai c entri in un sacco
lì perché non ti perché non riesce a
scavalcare schifoso l'aido perché se non
si scavalca poi come posso sfondare
niente quindi forse è meglio così
allora come insegna che possono rubare
addirittura una tv come la vecchia tv
vale un dollaro a beh dovreste vecchia
tv ma non potevo rubarla prima rubiamo
sempre alle stesse persone perfetto non
c'era prima st tv te lo giuro è comparsa
adesso la teiera teiere tostapane anche
la pentola che fanno un sacco di soldi
prendi la tv la tv uguale un dollaro
c'è veramente se la porta indietro devi
pagare tu praticamente
come hanno chiamato per chi è chiamato o
porca vacca mi ha visto e vabbè allora
facciamo così spetta è in aperto e
aperto prima tv prima tv però c'è una tv
la tv veloce veloce che rigoni la puglia
la pula veloce quanto tempo poi però
arriva la macchina mi arrestano cosi mi
arrestano film come la caricola carico
dovrà carico carica la parti parti mi
hanno preso non è vero carica c'è poi
niente se non sono fatto da punti a
farlo youtuber maledetto quello che
stava fuori ma che ci stai a fare fuori
dalla casa così ma dimmelo tu ti pare o
perfetto affetto
ora vado a vendere vecchia tv 60 dollari
ghana ladrata questa mamma mi ha
salutato regola cagata li ha per che
quindi possono affittarmi come ladro per
un giorno che carino rom pierobon quadro
rompigli piatti 1 ha scritto un annuncio
partito 50 dollari se vai dai beccare
gli rompe i piatti va bene io li accetto
tutti e due io non potrei piatti che che
gli rompo il quadro tutto lì rom
ho parcheggiato mi sa un pelo troppo
davanti alla porta scusatemi signori ma
devo rompervi piatti c'è scritto la
polizia sta cercando la mia auto what a
perché perché dopo bloccato il traffico
la scusa scusa e mi capo dei fare il
giro madonna che pignolo e devo spaccare
tutto
non ci credo hanno trovato l'auto non ha
trovato almeno se avessero trovato la
famiglia ora dell'eroe giacché siamo qua
dobbiamo qualcosa no ecco il quadro
posso rubare e spaccare spacchiamo molto
bene compito eseguito spacchiamo anche
lei i piatti schifo i piatti bene
infatti la teiera fonti tutto il mercato
mi ha beccato col tizio la via via via
via via via si è capito che non ci pensa
se scappi non ci prendono by light
accendi vai
ok ce l'ho fatta
miracolo divino meno male ho finalmente
si inizia con l'avere delle cose un po
più importanti
i power oy watson
io direi che i powell sono proprio
ricchi alla possibile azione possibile
ubicazione del bottino vai vediamo c'è
una stampante ria stampante di grande
valore nel salotto misure di sicurezza
in casa c'è una chiave di scorta la
porta d'ingresso in camera da letto
113 i powell devo vedere se riesco per
qualche strano motivo a riuscire a
rubare qualcosa questi può anche se la
vedo veramente difficile questi sono
messi un po troppo bene non so quanto io
riesca a fare questa coppia proviamoci
eccoci signori sono fieri scotta la
parte yingluck è già che posso entrare
qua è una cosa bellissima
però di notte magari o di giorno so se
c'è qualcuno che lei proprio quel
grimaldello per chico mine farle di
notte queste cose perché di giorno ma se
i ladri diurni via prima vede ecco
sarebbe molto più utile perché se spacco
le porte ad esso povera che in qualcuno
minimi scopra unico e allora cosa c'è
questa la camera da letto
e questa la chiave della porta di given
secondo me come la mia macchina
ma perché ma sapete guidare in questo
posto sto lavorando e basta
cribbio cosa fai giro schifosa o la vedi
che la strada a due corsie vai
nell'altra schifosa maledetta lurida ne
vendiamo a vendere quello che ho preso e
torniamo al prossimo che si lamenta per
dove parcheggi con lo ammazzo ve lo
giuro
vediamo se c'è qualcuno in casa prima di
tutto c'è una stampa ecco la stampante
grande valore porta permesso preso
perfetto
e stato un lavoro rapido veloce via
veloce tu non hai visto niente non hai
visto io sono quello da addetto alle
pulizie sto pulendo la stampa adesso
vado a pulirla se magari ci muoviamo
prima che arrivi la polizia ci muoviamo
tranquillo trapianti faccio niente io ho
preso a stampando la polizia e lenta
style.it tranquillo bella ciao polizia è
lentissima è stata veramente lenta
quindi via molto bene vediamo se me la
fa vendere blackberry elettronica
vecchia chitarra io ma 300 dollari
un water five devo tornare assolutamente
lì subito in più devo rubare questo
quadro ok faccio molti ma molti rubata
stavolta andiamo la taratura 300 dollari
porca shabak voce che stanno tipo ii
veloce auto parcheggiata in un posto
strano ma vedi che c'è gente che sta
dormendo porca vacca era sveglio
chitarra veloce
porca vacca preso un jobs che ri il
tizio anch'io mi sono spaventato perché
si è spenta
sì esiste o rubando e ho preso la
chitarra mi serviva devo fare diventare
nuovo jimi hendrix storiche alle barre
hai visto che non l'ho più parcheggiata
in un posto strano
fortuna che questi abitano fuori dal
limite nella mappa quindi posso uscire
subito casa o una chitarra a 300 dollari
cioè mi sono preso un job seeker per
averla ma vabbè è stato fighissimo direi
che per adesso possiamo concludere
l'acqua perché
ma cosa serve sta roba qua poi attirare
le cose so già come veramente incasinato
c'è poi fare un miliardo di robe che gli
spero che questa ladrata vi sia piaciuta
come al solito sei video che ci fosse un
momento non mi piace anche vari sacchi
colmi adottate descrizione se non
settembre iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]